O!Sapiens Expert: Sure.
FANATIC Agency: Плата ты. Когда, Ему, Писал Промт я не знаю как Просто Ты делал?
FANATIC Agency: А, что, если ему вгрузить?
FANATIC Agency: Ну, как, бы исходную нашу точку а. Вот то что, у нас есть на текущий момент что, мы вообще считаем что, мы не считаем?
FANATIC Agency: И как бы, исходя это из этого, уже посмотреть, Какую систему мотивацию предложил, Мне Кажется?
FANATIC Agency: Что сейчас, это Какой то космолет, как будто мы огромная. Корпорация какая, То?
FANATIC Agency: Мне кажется что, нам по, факту нужно остановиться на том чтобы, определить, какой, то нормальный, оклад?
FANATIC Agency: И определить там. Не знаю два. Три. Варианта возможного. Бонуса, сейчас, как бы, на текущий момент и все.
FANATIC Agency: Высота, понять, из за, чего могут быть идти бонусы и вообще не упираться?
FANATIC Agency: То, что эти бонусы могут, быть или не могут быть, и так далее, то есть как бонусы У стратегов. Не знаю. Там, бонусы. У там у. Леда.
FANATIC Agency: А у соответственно, там продюсера.
FANATIC Agency: Если мы. Идем там в мотивацию продюсера, тоже там переделать, Если не идем, пока только вот смотреть на?
FANATIC Agency: А. Там. Бонусы. Стратега.
FANATIC Agency: В каких случаях о невозможны? И Все, Мне кажется что, мы как будто былять усложняем задачу сейчас?
O!Sapiens Expert: Плане. Водных, Здесь были вгружены, красти водные, которые у нас есть сейчас, и было также запромктировано намерение прети к той точки, б которой мы, писали когда?
O!Sapiens Expert: I don't know if you know this, but I don't know if you know this, but I don't know if you know this. And, well, I don't know if you know this, but I don't know if you know this, but I don't know if you know this.
O!Sapiens Expert: Формулировали бизнес модель. И вот это все из в чем всей проблематики, которые сейчас, то здесь. Суть условного этого документа, сходится к, тому чтобы поддержать переход. К точки Б. Да, оно выглядит несколько?
O!Sapiens Expert: from the business model, and I think it's problematic, because it's just that it's too slow in the documentation, so I don't think it's possible, but it's very, very hard, so I don't think it's possible.
O!Sapiens Expert: Сложновато здесь. Есть при. Этом переходные периоды о не описаны но, то?
O!Sapiens Expert: Просто надо понять как, бы окей допустим мы. Сейчас Сильно все упрощаем и мы, это оставляем перманентно или мы. Это, оставляем на полгода. И, Ну, короче, нас, нет здесь. Тоже понимания да потому, что ну как бы, можно?
O!Sapiens Expert: На коленке. Сделать Какую то новую систему?
O!Sapiens Expert: В целом, сильно, проще, чем здесь предложена естественно. Но, Надо тогда понять окей и. С, этой, системой мы теперь живем отныне и впречь или Это временная система, или как?
FANATIC Agency: Но я думаю, что это должна быть какая то, ее, можно называть версия один?
FANATIC Agency: Система, которая настроится не только от нашего желания, но и от контекст, который есть сейчас на рынке. Контекст рынка, говорит о том что и двадцать шестой, и двадцать седьмой год?
FANATIC Agency: Будут продолжаться. Быть егибейшими?
FANATIC Agency: А Вот, поэтому в целом есть смотреть на тут горизонт планирования который, есть который, сейчас компания ставят и, не, знаю максимум планирует, там, на?
FANATIC Agency: Три месяца?
FANATIC Agency: Ну, давайте, Просто, с учетом, какой то еще переходный, там в. Модели. Закрытия. Долгов?
FANATIC Agency: И так далее. Нужно Понять когда, мы перейдем к этой новой системе там мотивации описать. Это.
FANATIC Agency: Поставить себе. Не знаю пока Промежуточную историю там. До?
FANATIC Agency: Не знаю Там Первого Квартала двадцать, седьмого года. Я бы точно. Так вот это ставила а потом, дальше уже смотреть?
FANATIC Agency: А че будет происходить с рынком насколько, мы Можем дальше эту системы мотивации. Там менять где то, можем, еще, какие, то бонусы добавлять и так далее.
FANATIC Agency: Есть ну, как, бы просто?
FANATIC Agency: Мы сейчас смотрим на весь рынок весь рынок урезает бонусы оставляя. Как бы окладной части не, за, то чтобы урезать бонусы. Я за то, чтобы?
FANATIC Agency: Сейчас не упароваться, в то, что мы сейчас сидим и, думаем за, что, бы нам еще эти бонусы.
FANATIC Agency: А дать?
FANATIC Agency: А вот?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей?
FANATIC Agency: С долгами в?
FANATIC Agency: Шесть, лям?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
Антон Аверьянов: I'm sorry, I didn't mean to interrupt you.
Антон Аверьянов: What's what's happening here?
O!Sapiens Expert: Час.
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну, Вот?
Антон Аверьянов: dot com.
Антон Аверьянов: Здесь. Бонусная Всей часть строятся вокруг проекта и, твои включенности В проект. Что. Вытащили с проекта дальше? Для Команды для развития, компании, и так далее?
Антон Аверьянов: I'm not sure if it's true that the Brexit protests in the United States have been repeated.
Антон Аверьянов: А есть, в этой системе?
Антон Аверьянов: Uh, yes, sir, this is Jamie.
Антон Аверьянов: У вас. Сейчас, Где активности, которые вне, проектные котору мы обсуждали, при записании, контент, на каких то историй выступления, имеет и так далее.
Антон Аверьянов: I think it's important to remember that this is an important part of our daily lives.
O!Sapiens Expert: Мне Кажется это, не вось четырнадцать?
Антон Аверьянов: Что то важно оставить?
Антон Аверьянов: That's the Vajrayana stage.
O!Sapiens Expert: Надо писать для. Начала то что, у нас тут уже никак не описан ни в каком, виде?
Антон Аверьянов: Да, да?
Антон Аверьянов: Hold on there.
Антон Аверьянов: Но мы же с вами договорились на прошлой встрече что за большие активности, которые это продовидимые, и много времени, отнимаются, то должно быть, какое то пащее время?
Антон Аверьянов: I'm not sure if you know this, but I'm not sure if you've heard of the Bolshoi Activities Secretary, but I'm not sure if you've heard of it.
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, мы даже проговаривали поводу этого бонуса, как в размере пятидесяти тысяч но. Я Не знаю кто то, про него проговаривал или, нет?
Антон Аверьянов: Ну, Искать да, да. Да, да?
Антон Аверьянов: Я бы не завтра вроде?
O!Sapiens Expert: Как донести тоже?
Антон Аверьянов: Переведи у Я сыпнулся не поговорить.
O!Sapiens Expert: Там, конечно, это. Все. Виртуальные выплаты по каналу.
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну? Да, здесь, фокусствую документы именно. На бонусыпроект Нежели, За какую. Дополнительную? Работу.
O!Sapiens Expert: Типы участия в бинарах проведению, бинаров, или ищуть счета написание статей?
O!Sapiens Expert: Что тут можно вручном режиме. Просто собираться, решать, не, то что, вы?
O!Sapiens Expert: Колосальные объемы?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей давайте Попробуем Еще, тогда этого. Простить и?
Антон Аверьянов: Перемотай, то была страница первые. Тридцать. Дней?
Антон Аверьянов: Где он там. Трех. Частный, поэтапный план, план перехода?
O!Sapiens Expert: Первые, тридцать. Дней?
O!Sapiens Expert: Не. Вот это. Вот?
Антон Аверьянов: Девяносто. Да, да, да, да, да Покажи?
O!Sapiens Expert: Или другое?
Антон Аверьянов: Окей ну Да, Давайте, Доупрощайте, и.
Антон Аверьянов: Степенно переходить на?
O!Sapiens Expert: Нян. Вот. Фильм?
Антон Аверьянов: Адам отпрайда?
FANATIC Agency: Мне кажется важно сейчас, зафиксировать вот этот вот как бы, план внедрения вот эти. Первые Этапы?
FANATIC Agency: Это?
FANATIC Agency: Ну. Там, не знаю, там план. По. Выплате долгов план. По. Выплате текущих от этих вот бонусов который сейчас, у нас есть в долгах?
FANATIC Agency: Зафиксировать, на каких как бы ну, как, бы за какие, Проекты. Вот. Мы финально доплачиваем там бонусы, которые, сейчас вот. Там движутся то, есть. Мы, уже договорились что за?
FANATIC Agency: Вот эти маленькие проекты мы. Не Платим бонус но у, нас еще продолжают работу там?
FANATIC Agency: Во вкусвел. У нас еще продолжает работу?
FANATIC Agency: Из старой системы мотивации. Ток Нервно Вкус пионер. Заканчивается Ну Пионер который Закончится, все?
O!Sapiens Expert: Пионер?
FANATIC Agency: Вот и дальше соответствен. Уже вот, как только эти проекты закончатся?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
Arina Mokrousova: Сбер банк. Еще У нас. С вами есть.
Arina Mokrousova: Табанк?
FANATIC Agency: А ты банк, т, банк, еще, Да?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы?
Arina Mokrousova: Это Упатья?
FANATIC Agency: Там уже нужно.
FANATIC Agency: Соответственно понимать, какая, будет вот это. Вот система. Там мотивации. У них да. Там далее.
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
FANATIC Agency: Уже после выплаты в этих проц. Мне Кажется что, на самом деле?
FANATIC Agency: Ну это И, является отправной точкой то, есть в тот, момент когда, мы выплатим?
FANATIC Agency: То есть, оклады, стается, прежним и Вот. Эти проценты которые мы, должны повод этим вот текущим. Проектам кажется что возможно. Вот?
FANATIC Agency: После этого момента уже должно что то, измениться и оклад должен поменяться потому, что перестает действовать предыдущая система.
FANATIC Agency: Возможно, это так, должно быть?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, На Практике это. Сложно. Реализуемо. Что мы, ну, де факто. Мало, вероятно, что. Выходим с. Должность, по процентам до появления, каких то новых проектов?
FANATIC Agency: Ну Почему, Магнит, то нам, гасят, большую часть?
O!Sapiens Expert: Из шести миллионов сколько. Три.
FANATIC Agency: Я не знаю сколько, я тебе сейчас на память не скажу. Ты. Можешь посмотреть в таблице ани.
O!Sapiens Expert: Мне нужно скидку?
FANATIC Agency: Вот не знаю вот.
FANATIC Agency: Но большую часть, он гасит Здесь просто. Нужно. Собираться по платежам то что магнита самый, большой платеж?
FANATIC Agency: И здесь нужно уже собираться и смотреть потому, что, исходя, из распределения там потому, что есть долгие по вашей зарплате то стосовно сколько, там?
FANATIC Agency: Вам нужно сейчас оплатить, и сколько из этого. Соответственно, мы можем потратить на погашение, вот этих процентов и так далее. То есть, это отдельный, какая то, встреча?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
FANATIC Agency: После того, как магнит нам, оплачут?
FANATIC Agency: Есть. Леопад?
O!Sapiens Expert: Если оплатит?
FANATIC Agency: Да, я. Уже?
FANATIC Agency: Не знаю?
O!Sapiens Expert: Пива?
FANATIC Agency: Что отнехожидать?
FANATIC Agency: Ближайшие. Платежи которые, у нас есть но. Они Оклады нам?
FANATIC Agency: Ну Какие То Погаси да, там и, вкус вел, и, клэврика И?
FANATIC Agency: Какой то часть мы?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, это, конечно, это, Сэджерс?
O!Sapiens Expert: Двигать усилено?
Антон Аверьянов: Себе дожать продать на этой На этой встрече все хорошо. Проект Небеснить.
O!Sapiens Expert: Кто?
Антон Аверьянов: Ну, я посмотрела против адекватный движевый чувак?
FANATIC Agency: А это, у вас будет встреча именно по эйчару с Эджерс и с нами. Нет?
Антон Аверьянов: Ну И Да?
Антон Аверьянов: Это Нечар. Это не ечар это. Фьючер. Вижн.
Антон Аверьянов: Эта встреча с сибис На. Следующей неделю выбираем слот?
FANATIC Agency: А. Угу?
FANATIC Agency: Где?
Антон Аверьянов: Я уже встречался с эчаром дипартаментом. Это вообще от них все началось они. Хотели сделать обучение. По трандаму?
Антон Аверьянов: Я Ариня рассказывал, но и у нас была встреча звонок. С Джерси там На Встрече. Стало очевидно. Что они, ждут, необучения. По трентам, чтобы, кто то им принес и?
Антон Аверьянов: Рассказал, как будет выглядеть бизнес модели в их бизнесе в будущем и, мы в этом заменили обучение. На продажу проекта По Фьючережам.
Антон Аверьянов: Позвонились на прошлом деле, Сэджеры Собсудили его вот. Я. Сейчас. Закинул там?
FANATIC Agency: Угу?
Антон Аверьянов: В презентажку там. Без цен без всего просто, вершний уровня у, пощупать туда не. Туда. Именно то?
FANATIC Agency: Оценивать, Если что, или ты просто какую то, запись встречу принесешь, чтобы, я посмотреть или, ты, позовешь мне на этот?
Антон Аверьянов: Я позову. Я позову позову Мы сейчас выберем нелен с немери.
FANATIC Agency: Окей?
Arina Mokrousova: Давайте, Проговоримо що, будемо робити з антоном?
Arina Mokrousova: Давайте, Проговорим что, будем делать система. Мотивации я еще. Скажу что у, нас же есть с антоном?
Arina Mokrousova: Дополнительний. Додат.
Arina Mokrousova: Дополнительный? Этот?
Arina Mokrousova: Мм. Задача. По трекам для спеціаліста?
Arina Mokrousova: Дополнительная задача. По трекам Для специалистов?
Arina Mokrousova: От?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот.
Arina Mokrousova: Ми для каті і діани?
Arina Mokrousova: То есть, мы для Кати и Дианы Трек уже сделали для лолы пока, нет. Мы его пока, не трогаем потому, что испытательный?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот. І у нас. В неї?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот и у, нас, и нее?
Arina Mokrousova: Ее, ну?
Arina Mokrousova: Но?
Arina Mokrousova: Треки?
Arina Mokrousova: Треки. Предлагать. Надо?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну?
Arina Mokrousova: Вже вкладах?
Arina Mokrousova: Уже дела. Опер, с какими то окладами вот соответственно, когда, мы будем думать об окладах?
Arina Mokrousova: Мы должен. Тоже еще в эти треки. Посмотреть?
Arina Mokrousova: Ми маємо?
Arina Mokrousova: И потом понять?
Arina Mokrousova: І?
Arina Mokrousova: Ммм?
Arina Mokrousova: С какого момента услова нам этот офер можем делать? Вот?
Arina Mokrousova: З якого моменту?
Arina Mokrousova: Этими новыми треками предполагающими, новые оклады?
O!Sapiens Expert: Говоришь. Офер то, этого типа описание, Трека или, это уже конкретное изменение в должностных обязанностях?
Arina Mokrousova: Деньги. Деньги. Да, конечно. Ну. То есть ну да, конечно, офер, это, из меня. Не долг ну то это По, факту. Ты. Вопрос своему сотруднику делаешь офер так же как, если бы ты?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну, То, є ну, ти?
O!Sapiens Expert: Угу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, да?
Arina Mokrousova: Нанимал, кого, то со сторону должен написать ему?
Arina Mokrousova: Написати йому?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну, От, Новий трек?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот Новый трек что, он, в себя включает и деньги вот. Как. Вы?
Arina Mokrousova: Так далі. Случаться. Офір.
Arina Mokrousova: Тогда случится. Офер?
Arina Mokrousova: Просто описывать трек, рассказывать словом там, кате вот кем. Ты. Можешь быть?
Arina Mokrousova: Просто трек, розказувати. Словом. Каті. Ким. Ти. Можеш, Бити?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну, просто?
Arina Mokrousova: Но, это, наверное, какую то решить проблему просто?
Arina Mokrousova: Катина вижена собственного, там профессионального развития. Но это будет скорее какая, то, каучинговая Сессия, чем?
O!Sapiens Expert: В рамках этого трека. Там Это связка с грейдами Это Какая система координат?
Arina Mokrousova: Рэк Это, Не про грейд это Про развитие.
O!Sapiens Expert: Гм?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот а дальше. Ну. Спеціаліст Ее?
Arina Mokrousova: Дату. Что катя, Есть Грейд вот А Дальше, ну, Специалист. Утловный.
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
Arina Mokrousova: 2. От в нас. Щось так получається.
Arina Mokrousova: Два разных синевера могут уметь разные треки от нас. Жеста, как и получается?
Arina Mokrousova: У нас. Одіана 1 Дім трек?
Arina Mokrousova: Словом. Там. Бренд стратек, І ми, Поки думаємо над фокусом. Бренд Роботодацями?
Arina Mokrousova: От. А. У каті Там бізнес? Стратекс?
Arina Mokrousova: Спеціалізація. Разом.
O!Sapiens Expert: Я. Вопрос. Именно к системе координат как она, строится?
O!Sapiens Expert: Тустита. Не. Граит?
O!Sapiens Expert: Это?
O!Sapiens Expert: Ну. Я, Не, знаю, как это?
Arina Mokrousova: Сценарій?
O!Sapiens Expert: Сценарий развития. Вот сценарий развития. Он. Как, Должен привязываться к систему мотивации но? В плане как, это, на шаг на, два на три вперед или. Это просто вот только конкретно это. Сейчас позиция я. Просто не очень понимаю если, вот это система координат?
Антон Аверьянов: Мацепт?
O!Sapiens Expert: В этой?
Антон Аверьянов: У тебя план развития, у тебя план развития, привязан к Грытам и ты идешь план развития чтобы, тном, числя подниматься по гредам. Крыты, должен, быть привязан к систему мотивации?
O!Sapiens Expert: В этом треке?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей, ну?
Антон Аверьянов: То, как мы, сейчас смотрели, документы там это как, то, сделал?
O!Sapiens Expert: Час перефраззируют для моего понимания, словно, у кате сейчас какой. Играет?
Arina Mokrousova: Аа, Плюс?
O!Sapiens Expert: И вот этот новая роль она. Мидл плюс. Или, нет?
Антон Аверьянов: Не от у нее трек. Развитие к синиру?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну?
O!Sapiens Expert: Так?
Arina Mokrousova: Так?
O!Sapiens Expert: И Трек развития. К. Синер предполагает, что следующий офер условно, Это, синьер?
Антон Аверьянов: Но дака. Тут еще может живить разведка. Развелка. Бджона?
Arina Mokrousova: Ні. Ее. Твійду?
Arina Mokrousova: Ставить суму плюс, ставить суму?
Arina Mokrousova: От?
Arina Mokrousova: Та яке ім'я Швейду?
O!Sapiens Expert: В частности?
Антон Аверьянов: Но пока металл. Плюс Мы с ними договаривались чтобы, внешние не меняем название но, внутри мы. Понимаем что, они приходит на другую систему. Да, и она будет. Метал. Плюс, Да?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну, я?
Arina Mokrousova: Я думаю, що У Каті?
Arina Mokrousova: Аа, А. На ее тод спец которий, ее?
Arina Mokrousova: Ее, Короче, Трек Привязан. К новой в. Этой бизнес модели ту би?
Arina Mokrousova: Його коротше Трек. Прив'язаний бізнес-моделі. Тобі?
Arina Mokrousova: И предполагается, что она будет одним из опорно Специалистов. Который обеспечивают переход к этой модели, и будет она непосредственно участвовать в разработке этого нового продукта. Ну.
Arina Mokrousova: І. Ну.
Антон Аверьянов: Да?
Arina Mokrousova: Типа проекта. Она. Будет делать?
Arina Mokrousova: Тіпа проєкт. Вона, Буде Робити?
O!Sapiens Expert: Мы?
Arina Mokrousova: У нее должен быть другой оклад.
Arina Mokrousova: У нього?
Arina Mokrousova: Онлайн?
Arina Mokrousova: От?
O!Sapiens Expert: Прифрызирую у меня. Сейчас. Мидл Плюс. Она переходит на Мидл. Плюс?
Arina Mokrousova: Она, пока никуда не переходит Она Смедла, плюс, переходит на синера этот.
Arina Mokrousova: Вона, поки нікуди не переходить вона.
Arina Mokrousova: Это занимает время Вот?
Arina Mokrousova: Це, займаєте время. Вот?
O!Sapiens Expert: Где? То?
Arina Mokrousova: Но, а у нее другой трек становится она. Становится, Мидл плюс Другой, конфигурации и она двигается, одновременно и в другую конфигурацию?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну А, у?
Arina Mokrousova: И в другой в другой грей то Есть, у нее случается с ней и вертикальный и. Горизонтальный, ост, это катень случая. Этот Трост называется диагональный когда одновременно и, вверх растешь и, меняешь конфигурацию роль.
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей?
O!Sapiens Expert: Это, я понимаю. А вот это. Оно описано, как то?
O!Sapiens Expert: Структурно?
Arina Mokrousova: Что ты имеешь еду в Чем Конкретно Выражаться будет?
O!Sapiens Expert: Вот это, словно, я. Назвем матрица или. Система координат?
O!Sapiens Expert: В плане изменений?
O!Sapiens Expert: Вот есть сейчас, типа, в какой то момент останет синьор пока, это не случилось. Следующий. Промежуточный этап это. Условно как, это?
O!Sapiens Expert: Владиявичем?
O!Sapiens Expert: По Диагонале. Но как бы де факто или не знаю в, какой симе координат это миддл. Плюс?
O!Sapiens Expert: Это не сразу. Синьер. Вот это разница между этими двумя точками. Она описана, каким, то?
O!Sapiens Expert: За понятным языком?
Arina Mokrousova: Да, но у нас же есть ее заполненная. Матрица компетенций.
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
Arina Mokrousova: Не Знаю вот это. Точка а.
Arina Mokrousova: Сегодняшнее, и есть понимание. Трека?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
Arina Mokrousova: И того, какие компетенции должны быть прогружены по матрице, чтобы стать синером. И видны. Ее Западающий Компетенции.
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, о Промежуточные?
Arina Mokrousova: Что, Ты имеешь воду подпромежутной?
O!Sapiens Expert: Связь?
O!Sapiens Expert: Трек. Это несколько шагов. Так?
Arina Mokrousova: Нет?
O!Sapiens Expert: Один шаг сразу?
Arina Mokrousova: Трек. Это сценарий твоего развития.
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, Но у тебя в этом сценарии. Один Единственный снышаг?
Антон Аверьянов: Я там?
Антон Аверьянов: Там много активностей. Эти активности, привязанные к матрице компетенций, которую мы с ребятами рассматривали, то, Есть мы, в треке просто. Да.
O!Sapiens Expert: Это понятно.
O!Sapiens Expert: Новы?
Антон Аверьянов: Что там, у всех, по разному влад у кате более там круто больше кто, меньше?
O!Sapiens Expert: Давайте. Я, просто не сейчас я. Часто совсем Забылся я не Понимаю как. Собственно, вы предлагаете, структурировать, это и привязывать к услонну Окладу и какому то не было бонусу Если?
Антон Аверьянов: Психоз Разные треки.
Антон Аверьянов: Как лада?
Антон Аверьянов: Как ладу привязан, не трек как, ладу привязан грейд а, треки. Ведут. Грейдам?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей. Вот, это взаимосвязь она. Для меня До конца непонятна?
O!Sapiens Expert: Можешь мне ее не надо понимать?
O!Sapiens Expert: Но для того, чтобы нам сформировать систему мотивации, в нас должна быть какая, то единая структура и системы координа я пока, ее не понимаю может, Это, только я не понимаю?
Arina Mokrousova: Да, И вот непонятно?
Arina Mokrousova: Какие тебе компоненты нужны чтобы понять?
Arina Mokrousova: То есть, вот, условно у нас. Есть Мидл, Это грейд И синер Это. Грейд.
Arina Mokrousova: Для этих городов нужно определить оклады?
Arina Mokrousova: И это у тебя. Сейчас, есть.
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей Но, Катя уже у. Нас катя уже мидл. Плюс?
Arina Mokrousova: Не вот а дальше.
Arina Mokrousova: Да, то есть, ну, понятно, что, можно, если, ты, знаешь, сколько акватум медлана и сколько, У Синера, Ты, можешь посчитать акватуум меду плюс?
Arina Mokrousova: Ват?
Arina Mokrousova: Это понятно, кого то тут. Просто решается сдачка. Вот а дальше. Получается. Вот у нас есть стоимость. Медлайн Стоимость Синьора, стоимость. Мидл плюс И дальше. Есть.
Arina Mokrousova: Трек, який предполагає каті на конкретно?
Arina Mokrousova: Трек, который предполагает кате на конкретное движение?
Arina Mokrousova: От Мідла плюс в сторону senior.
Arina Mokrousova: От медла, плюс в сторону синера?
O!Sapiens Expert: М?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот.
Arina Mokrousova: І там, плюс, у нього з'явиться просто новий новий можна сказати об'язаний. Конфігурація. Ролі?
Arina Mokrousova: И там у нее получается, ей. Нужно развивать определенные компетенции по матрице. Плюс у. Нем появится просто новые, новые можно, сказать, обязанности новая, конфигурация. Ролей?
Arina Mokrousova: І вопрос?
Arina Mokrousova: И вот в этой. Схеме. Какие компоненты тебе нужно сейчас понять для? Того чтобы, ответить на этот твой вопрос?
O!Sapiens Expert: Как минимум?
Arina Mokrousova: То, чого вмієш веду?
Arina Mokrousova: Когда Ты Говоришь в промежуточные в эти, точке ты че имеешь введу?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да. Ну. Какой.
Arina Mokrousova: Проміжок, очної, оклади тіпа біля чого?
Arina Mokrousova: Промежуточные оклады типа величе?
O!Sapiens Expert: Не. Но здесь грейд То, не меняется при. Этом?
O!Sapiens Expert: Вот в этом промежуточном?
Arina Mokrousova: До следующего перфоманс ревью. Да да. То, есть, она как Бы в Процессе выполнения условно?
Arina Mokrousova: В процесі. Виповнення, условно?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
Arina Mokrousova: Этого. Ну. Как, бы в процессе движения к грейду вот у Нее. Есть оклад.
Arina Mokrousova: Мидл. Плюс?
Arina Mokrousova: Middle. Плюс?
Arina Mokrousova: И она пока двигается к Синиеру.
Arina Mokrousova: І?
O!Sapiens Expert: М?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот она. Существует с окладами плюс, но, у нее могут быть бонусы за выполнение там отдельных каких. То, Задач вебинар, там, сделала или там, не, знаю вот?
Arina Mokrousova: Моєї системи. Там?
Arina Mokrousova: В моей. Системе. Там?
Arina Mokrousova: Допустим, как Мидл как то, приложило усилие прямо?
Arina Mokrousova: Допустимо прям?
Arina Mokrousova: Повлиял на проект, и так далее Вот она. Условно. В этом треке развивается?
Arina Mokrousova: А потом, там, через год, у него или, через полтора там. Проходит перформанс ревью. Мы, определяем. Но сколько, у нее поматрится компетенций?
Arina Mokrousova: Произошло Улучшение?
Arina Mokrousova: И принимаем решение о том, можем, ли, мы сказать что она уже, достигла синера или нет меняем, оклад или не. Меняем?
O!Sapiens Expert: Гм?
O!Sapiens Expert: Есть условный Офер. Сейчас, он по сути, на текущую позицию?
O!Sapiens Expert: Если то, пошло пошли через годжи мы, меняем или, не меняем?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну, да Но, я, считаю что, просто та роль которую, мы ей предлагаем она кобя. Все. Одно предполагает работу больше, в новой бизнес модели?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да, да, это понятно?
Arina Mokrousova: І?
Arina Mokrousova: И?
Arina Mokrousova: Діани?
Arina Mokrousova: Для меня будто, бы у нее все таки должен быть какой то, другое чуть, отличный озер. От озеро. Дианы?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот. Аа?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот потому, что Диана как раз, например, пока?
Arina Mokrousova: А. На. В Нову бізнес-модель нікуди не. Ідіот?
Arina Mokrousova: Она в новую бизнес модель. Никуда Не Идет?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот.
Arina Mokrousova: Про що я говорю?
Arina Mokrousova: Понимаешь. Про Чей Говорю?
O!Sapiens Expert: Я, с одной стороны понимаю, с, другой стороны не понимаю как это, вписать новому окейлону давайте показу надо Сначала. С моделью определиться, потом, уже будем в деталем уходить?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну. Коротше, Ее, кейсу?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну, Короче, если. Все Свести вот пока к какиному кейсу?
Arina Mokrousova: Я не знаю який, у них, оклади ну просто Вот Візьму. З. Потолка якщо у нього оклад 100 000?
Arina Mokrousova: Я не знаю какие, у них оклады ну просто вот возьму. С, Потолка если у него оклад сто тысяч?
Arina Mokrousova: Но это, как бы мало для той позиции, которую мы ей предлагаем даже, если, она сейчас пока не синяя?
Arina Mokrousova: Навіть зараз, поки не снієр?
Arina Mokrousova: Ми там просто їй трек Написали тіпа Катя Ти будеш. Опорним Іграком?
Arina Mokrousova: Перший блок.
Arina Mokrousova: Продукта?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну. Тіпа із. Окладом. 100 000.
Arina Mokrousova: Ну?
O!Sapiens Expert: Да Это понятно. Тут. Вопрос не не столько как оклады сколько, к проценту?
Arina Mokrousova: Типу. Це просто стока на ринку?
O!Sapiens Expert: Тут. Ты. Же Знаешь что есть другая, страна?
O!Sapiens Expert: Молокость. Это процент?
Arina Mokrousova: Я помала?
O!Sapiens Expert: М?
Arina Mokrousova: Я. Я у нас вами розгор.
Arina Mokrousova: А Системі мотивації. Ну.
O!Sapiens Expert: Да?
Arina Mokrousova: А. Я просто курю. Що у нас, ще є треки? І?
Arina Mokrousova: Принцип?
Arina Mokrousova: Нам своїм. Зрозуміло?
Arina Mokrousova: Ми потім зможемо. Та синхронірвати з треками?
Arina Mokrousova: От?
O!Sapiens Expert: Окей. Ну. Давайте, Попробуем?
O!Sapiens Expert: Сделать новый подход к станку?
Arina Mokrousova: Нам почути, що проговорити?
O!Sapiens Expert: Наверно, по конях?
Arina Mokrousova: Ее, по проєктам е мм?
Arina Mokrousova: Я. Би хотіла просто?
Arina Mokrousova: Ее, знаєте, мм?
Arina Mokrousova: Просто, щоб ви знали вот.
Arina Mokrousova: Ааа?
Arina Mokrousova: Із?
Arina Mokrousova: Аа?
Arina Mokrousova: Меня, ее портал і. Такава.
Arina Mokrousova: Ну, там. В. Цілому ситуація, проста і достаточно лояльний клієнт?
Arina Mokrousova: Собою?
Arina Mokrousova: І поки не ясно?
Arina Mokrousova: В общем там, как будто вот я. Знаю. Что будет, встреча?
Arina Mokrousova: Там. Вот я знаю з тобою встреча.
Arina Mokrousova: По территориям в понедельник вот. Этот вопрос надо обсудить и, я. Думаю что, возможно, понадобится?
Arina Mokrousova: По. Я думаю, що возможно, понадобиться?
Антон Аверьянов: Да?
Arina Mokrousova: Промежуточный синг с кириллом Перед Вай сессии Вот?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот.
Arina Mokrousova: Тож преже, чем?
Arina Mokrousova: Тож?
Arina Mokrousova: Гему Какие то гипотезы показывать?
Arina Mokrousova: Йому? Які, тоді. Потязі показувати?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот, надо. Сначала посмотреть. Внутричь. Получается, мы с. Дианой. Это обстудили, что, возможно, какие то территории накравтятся?
Arina Mokrousova: Который натягиваются на два этих направления.
Arina Mokrousova: Но, возможно, и нет. Вообщем, пока непонятно от У нас. Счета территории кравству и понедельник. Обсудите и там, вполне вероятно, что, ну?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну, Возможно, і, ну?
Антон Аверьянов: Да?
Arina Mokrousova: Нам з керівником зустрічатися?
Arina Mokrousova: Нам Принцесс с кириллом Встречаться.
Arina Mokrousova: Вот а портал Мене в. Цілому ее?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот, а портал у меня в целом?
Arina Mokrousova: Он.
Arina Mokrousova: Беспокоит, потому что он?
Arina Mokrousova: Проєкт?
Arina Mokrousova: Как будто наиболее из них всех испринимарских проектов похож на настоящий большой проект?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот ее?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот.
Arina Mokrousova: Ви можете, такий же?
Arina Mokrousova: Может, вечерплюс, все Такой же?
Arina Mokrousova: Гіпотез?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот где прямо будет большой воркшоп с командой. На управление брендом, где будет там Повноценные Разработка Гипотез?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот Я рассчитываю просто на то, что фьючерпрув пройдет пораньше.
Arina Mokrousova: Вот, я.
Arina Mokrousova: І можна буде. Ну. Коротше, тут?
Arina Mokrousova: И можно будет воспользоваться всеми там наработками. И тот же сценарий воркшопа может подрезать, или что то еще. Ну. Короче, Тут?
Антон Аверьянов: Я на сам деле больше переживаю красов, чем портал?
Arina Mokrousova: Це за портал?
Антон Аверьянов: Портал да. Большой, бизнес действующий но, там. Ребята. Признают что, они, никогда, на, эту территорию не заходили они в общем с доверием, слушают, и, ну, вообще, город чуваки, видите, нас.
Антон Аверьянов: И с ними можно обсуждать фьючпруг. Другая, история там. Есть как, бы такой профессорский цинизм Егора который десять раз, это все видел. Сам проходил. И мы, знаем что, там уже у них немного не работает и это, на, сам деле называется значить нам большее беспокойство?
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
Антон Аверьянов: И портал фючпроф Все. Отличается с тем чтобы, фючпроф есть что, то похожее на платформу и, ребята, говорят, что, она, им нравится?
Антон Аверьянов: Правда, Поэтому Катя, Дожимаюсь тем чтоб она из это убичу профильм, то что, то, сделала?
Антон Аверьянов: Утобваримая?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну?
Arina Mokrousova: Я коротше ее я. Клієнта.
Arina Mokrousova: А я з другої позиції. Вот?
Антон Аверьянов: Мы?
Arina Mokrousova: Аа, Просто Діана Перший раз працює ці проєкти вот.
Arina Mokrousova: Ее і, вона поки, ну тіпа?
Arina Mokrousova: Вони зможуть на нього. Там. Тоже потрібно спаратиться?
Антон Аверьянов: Ну, я?
Антон Аверьянов: Я с ней поговорю но, помнишь это то, желание. Дианы Больше креативные, истории и так, далее на. Сам деле. Я. Такого. Рассматриваю, как, знаешь Такой проект. Который могут призмениться в креативное агентство и по, факту нужна такая, около, креативная платформа для.
Антон Аверьянов: Для Игби до сищного направления?
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну, Може, Бути?
Arina Mokrousova: Я думаю, що тут?
Arina Mokrousova: Ми, ну?
Arina Mokrousova: Ааа?
Arina Mokrousova: На лолі?
Arina Mokrousova: 3 ее?
Arina Mokrousova: М, 4. Проєкти. Стають.
Arina Mokrousova: Вот просто в нього починається магніт?
Антон Аверьянов: Фильм?
Arina Mokrousova: І воркшоп?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот. Я не знаю що, він ми. З тобою?
FANATIC Agency: Какой воркшоп по аклаврике? Нет, У двадцать седьмого. Он. Позже. Подготовка Ты имеешь в, эду?
Arina Mokrousova: Підготовка, підготовка, Так, підготовка?
FANATIC Agency: Ну. Здесь. Я. Поняла о, чем ты говоришь но клэврика она, если, Что. Движимая. Потому Что там, уже, чуть, чуть, двигаются сроки. Из за того, что, мы. На понедельник, Вылазим со следованием?
Arina Mokrousova: Угу?
FANATIC Agency: И если, что, как бы, К Клэврику мы можем где то подвинуть на?
FANATIC Agency: Типа, два, три, дня для, того чтобы, в параллели у там, не стало ну И, как. То я надеюсь, что никки. Хиллз Уже Перейдет из стадии?
FANATIC Agency: Активны. К этому моменту?
FANATIC Agency: С другой страны, ну, как бы мы, тоже уже можем стопнуться и, сказать, ребята?
FANATIC Agency: Закончились все возможные операции. Можем дальше еще дотюнивать. Но Не Знаю за дуб, гост, уже. За Какой то?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну, Да, я, корочес узнать чисто с точки зрения фокуса стратега говорю?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну. Я Короче, знаєте, чисто, з, точки, Зрения фокусу стратеги говорю?
Arina Mokrousova: Ват?
Arina Mokrousova: Потому, что на клаврике тоже ситуация непонятна никогда. Бы вижу что, она переживает?
Arina Mokrousova: Теж. Ситуація?
Arina Mokrousova: Вот.
Arina Mokrousova: От?
Arina Mokrousova: Тоже конпет дел сам. Клиент там. Гипотезы. Они будут. Кравтить без меня?
Arina Mokrousova: Сам клієнт. Там гіпотези. Вони будуть красти. Без меня.
Arina Mokrousova: Вот.
Arina Mokrousova: От?
Arina Mokrousova: Воркшоп. Буду Делать. Без меня, Я буду. Водкать?
Arina Mokrousova: Астон?
Arina Mokrousova: Паста?
Arina Mokrousova: Я Брю мы, С тобой это, обсудин, какие. То, есть варианты еще? Пятница Ну короче.
Arina Mokrousova: Які там є варіанти, Що, Ну, Коротше?
FANATIC Agency: Угу?
Arina Mokrousova: Ну. И вкусвилл, это. Классика классика. Нашего заведения вкусвилл.
Arina Mokrousova: Ну, І в, класика нашого?
FANATIC Agency: Да, Хорошо?
Arina Mokrousova: Я не знаю надеюсь, мы что, то придумаем вот. Но?
Arina Mokrousova: Пока тоже. Он.
Arina Mokrousova: Не самый понятно.
FANATIC Agency: Так у нас. Через минуту. Встреча, Следующая.
Arina Mokrousova: Да?
Антон Аверьянов: Ты добродес?
FANATIC Agency: Мы. Мы оставляем эти в хэцке Пока, арина В, отпуске будет или обсуждаем поэтому?
FANATIC Agency: По ходу. Нужны. Будут или, нет?
Антон Аверьянов: Давайте. Обсуждать походу?
FANATIC Agency: Угу окей?
Антон Аверьянов: Класс?
Arina Mokrousova: Да, тогда, ладно, давайте, пока.
FANATIC Agency: Давайте, На связи по крымка?
Антон Аверьянов: Как вернется без по дате Я, К, тебе сразу сразу вернул что?
FANATIC Agency: Хорошо?
Антон Аверьянов: Я с. Моргов, в четырнадцать созванилась, будем. Отказываться на твок?
FANATIC Agency: Ага?
FANATIC Agency: Супер! Спасибо?
FANATIC Agency: Давай?
Arina Mokrousova: Пока?
FANATIC Agency: Пока?